lately
the kalila videos have been get the
clips have been getting more views than
the Brennan videos
and it's because of a lot of people that
we tell like pod boy and all these
others she's fascinatingly evil because
a lot of people didn't realize how bad
she was until people because
this show her the tiger belly didn't
have
the same listenership before I mean it
has its fans of course but but
right after the entire Bobby cheating
thing or her cheating thing and the
Brendan chop and all that [ __ ] that's
when the more people started looking at
the show and people start going back and
looking at old episodes of the show
so uh this is from xlp we've plugged him
before
uh and he's such a boy xlp
so uh this one is a super cut
of the most sadistic women in comedy I
won't hit my dog I don't hit anybody I
got slapped in the face by the way who
hit you in the face kalila
let's hear that again you want to hear
that again look at the face the face I
won't hit my dog I don't hit anybody I
got slapped in the face by the way who
hit you in the face kalyla like
backhanded my face hard I have a new
girl guys can I tell you about her
please please Bob okay I met her on
Tinder and she's half Filipino the
second this is from Owen a this is when
they first met okay wow through the
third night we went out oh and she goes
I'm violet because I'm violent wow what
does that mean and she goes it shouldn't
say anything and then we made out some
more and she goes I hate you and she
punched me in the face she really
punches
she warned you you stupid [ __ ] idiot
sorry I'm sorry she punched him in the
face
so wait a second and then you still
stayed with her after that no guys let's
not jump the gun maybe this is a totally
different chick okay Filipino who's
violent and crazy got it oh Frozen is
that you from the age of 15 through 19
and one of the reasons why I have the
tattoo on my forearm is to cover the
scars this big black blog is there
because at 17 I lost a bet to a guy I
had a crush on and I tattooed his name
so she lied and said the reason she has
the black there's the cover up her
self-cutting but then it was because she
because she's an idiot she tattooed a
guy's name there
man the more people dig oh yeah on my
wrist again in Las Vegas
for Life Choices and I had to tattoo
over it four times I have real feelings
for this girls guys okay
how you're talking about her why Violet
is she crazy if she was molested
well good question Jim molested when I
was eight years old I felt sudden like
we've played this one before urge like a
sexual urge to do the same to either a
pet a doll or a real person or a real
child and you know what I hate to say it
now but like I took another cousin of
mine who I was eight and she was six and
you know what I mean that's like there
were things that I would probably did
that were highly inappropriate for an
eight-year-old yeah because it was being
done to me I would collect all like my
dogs had ticks and when the ticks would
suck up so much blood it'll be all fat
so I'd get a magnifying glass and then
put the tick under it until I have the
sun like like sear through its skin
until it would pop so that tick would
burst from
whoa that's just burning bugs that's not
a big deal oh so like with magnifying
glass like if the Sun hits them that's
so dark it gets so dark we don't have
babies we've killed two wait
wait
what
huh I'm backing up sorry guys let's hear
that again so like with magnifying glass
like if the Sun hits it got so dark it
gets so dark we don't have babies but
we've killed two wait really yeah
colleges I've been asking her for
[ __ ] 12 hours a day every day it's
like I've been asking can we have a baby
and she's like not with you we have
seven animals can you can we have a baby
not with you wow
we live together her niece lives with us
we're a family and we'll have [ __ ]
turkey basted myself with his [ __ ]
sperm which I believe so that really is
that's hurtful because uh we killed two
babies I am not the one so they've had
two abortions is that what they're
saying yeah who asked for an open
relationship and that's a [ __ ] fact
the truth of that is I intercepted
something alluding to Bobby and another
woman in Hawaii that is even how the
conversation ended up to having an open
relationship I didn't instigate it I
didn't start it I didn't cheat Bobby can
corroborate this story because I never
did anything like that in the 10 years
you know I never looked at another girl
yeah really I've never and I was very
like kind of loyal to her you know I
mean there's no flirtatiousness I never
did any of that I never hung out with
girls really no I never did it
um yeah so I went I got my bachelor's in
nursing from Cal State Long Beach yeah
and then when I met Bobby he was like
are you sure you want to do that
and I'm like are you trying to derail my
life because my mom's about to stab you
trying to tell her daughter not to
become a nurse I I did nursing last
minute because I could you imagine I was
a nurse yes Bobby probably saved a lot
of lives he did
coming up on like Financial hardships so
I was like okay let me just be quick
with the nursing get my Nursing degree
get a job got the job I can't help but
feel like if this is the nurse's episode
well you're allowed to talk Esther
what's going on
wait no she's always allowed to she
chooses that's what we like about Esther
is that she just chooses to not talk but
perhaps the real nurse should take it
away I'm not a real nurse you guys oh we
were talking about donuts and I went to
you know the funny bird is when they
dress up like nurses they all really do
look like the nurses yes the entire Vibe
nowhere is a better place to start here
with baby murder yeah you know what
though he got me pregnant off of
pre-cum pre-cum whoa yeah at the very
end of my last video I went over a poem
titled milk where class
do you know what I fantasize and that's
nothing with my my fantasies go crazy
being [ __ ] into by 10 men
hey
uh at first
first first first
[Applause]
go for it yeah you don't you don't want
to be the Caboose on that train yeah
yeah you don't want to be exactly I
don't want to be first on that train I
don't even want to I don't want to get
on that train I don't want to be the
dinner cart yeah somebody take a taxi or
an Uber
no you know he don't want to be Bobby
who has to eat her out later that night
oh come on man
man oh [ __ ] he's licking out every La
Comics come
I left out oh [ __ ] Christ she's
oozing like a Boston cream donut last
few lines where she talks about how the
living out of these fantasies has
resulted in abortions which she now
regrets I chose to not include this I
thought abortions are awesome you never
regret them that's what I was told
right the media said you're supposed to
shout your abortions because I thought
that she felt genuine and I've been
doing that I've been shouting at people
who have abortions hashtag shout your
abortion when I stand outside of Planned
Parenthood and I get a bull horn and I
shout at them
Morse and assume that she had since kept
this private as a result I was rushing
to release the video after I came across
their website and I didn't have time to
fully immerse myself in the lore and it
turns out that she opened by the way
this is again to plug it xlp
he brags about killing Bobby's children
we don't have babies but we've killed
two not only that but also intentionally
allowing herself to get pregnant knowing
that she would later have to get an
abortion
wait what
if you think I'm exaggerating let's look
at our own words you were simply a
carton of milk I thirsted for in two
places of my body that so fervently
welcomed you in I was a fool for
drinking you in this is cringier than
jerking off dogs
she's basically just a bipolar like dark
Triad complete psychopath who never
matured past High School on top of it
what you're right one that but also you
know we talk a lot about Brendan and
rightfully so about how he just
basically locked his way into what he's
doing same thing with kalila kalila if
it wasn't for [ __ ] Bobby nobody would
know she would be a nurse like you said
earlier she'd just be a a nurse
I already said Filipino nurse
he suffered as a child she
beat me endlessly and brutally growing
up like internment style she goes into
great detail about this trauma in her
poem from June 5th 2014 titled shampoo
bottle this
morning she's the worst
look women you're you can either Vote or
write poems but you can't do both okay
really outlines the beginning of her
sociopathic Association of love with
abuse I asked my mama why she punched me
in the mouth she said I had broken the
lid of the shampoo bottle she had paid
top peso for my braces so I didn't
understand the Sugar Ray Leonard strike
to the OS okay real quick you're a
terrible writer because you're a woman
but on top of that well she's not
telling you she probably tried to [ __ ]
the dog with a shampoo bottle she's
probably leaving that part out of the
story that was the main issue I think
that they had was the shampoo was ruined
yet I don't even recall the slightest
throb from the bottom lip she had split
open the air was so thick with her own
sadness it's like sweat it's like sweat
on a hot summer sidewalk
hey women you all write the same you
guys [ __ ] stork
the blank was blank the kind of blank
that reminded me of blank you [ __ ]
all women are 11th grade level writers
it's annoying
that all I could feel and hear was my
mama's heart crippling I don't know who
her tears were for if they were for my
it's always like adjective extra
unneeded adjective
for no reason father or Another Man by
the way more words don't make you a
better writer that's the lot of problem
with this it's a lot of redundancies
with the way women write you know and at
10 I understood so little all I knew is
always it was if the noun was an
adjective like a plant like in a season
exactly yeah
and victimizing others to pass officers
best of times it was the blurst of times
[Laughter]
even saying on Twitter it's true I've
used to ha I used I use less brain cells
since the change what years ago that she
was a literal genius that yeah 2014 she
tweeted out this before she was
semi-famous that she had an IQ of 146.
as a night okay but she took when I was
like Facebook IQ tests
probably I guess oh this looks like Mike
David 146. it is what's my IQ
147. yeah confirmed
remember when we covered that remember
when we covered that Owen video
do you think any of the great minds this
one send you that stuff in their IQs
no no the the greatest Minds in history
has never even tested their IQs they
were sitting around trying to figure out
what space dust is made of yeah sorry we
were too busy working on the Manhattan
Project yeah yeah we were we weren't
asking our mom to get on a [ __ ] a
[ __ ] YouTube stream and demand that
everybody listen to her about how smart
I am God remember that [ __ ] I miss those
days man I'm not gonna lie to you hate
them this next one is pure fan
speculation but it seems equally as
plausible this one centers around
Bobby's time spent supposedly in rehab
although as we covered in the last video
leaked text from Bobby's brother calling
to question whether or not he went to a
rehab center at all his brother claims
that kalila arranged for Bobby to be
admitted to a psych ward presenting it
as a standard rehab facility Bobby's
account of the event remember scalia's
admitted to being 5150 twice three times
three oh I apologize she got
the hat trick yeah she got the trace
okay events seem to match up with his
brother's portrayal as well they take
your phone and everything you have
nothing he called me from the pay
they're giving me 12 pills I don't know
what the [ __ ] is in this thing they had
me in this room
next to a man that doesn't sound like
rehab that sounds like a psych ward like
you were saying right yeah who was
65 rehab doesn't give you 12 pills no
psych wards give you 12 fills rehabs
really try to give you as little pills
as possible
a [ __ ] a rehab might give you
Ibuprofen if you're hurting or something
yeah we'll let you have coffee and
smokes and that's it
foreign
half naked
[Music]
um
and literally like we're as close as me
and Kyla is now crazy
and he's going like this
yeah bro I don't think that's rehab
doesn't sound like rehab that doesn't
sound like rehab
every minute so what I do is I grab all
my [ __ ] and I go straight to the lobby
the lobby was when I got real scared
what a shit-eating grin on her face
while he tells us oh she loves this look
I know this is still keep in mind she's
a sociopath I mean easily easily I think
she's a psychopath I I agreed okay
sociopath is too light of a label for
her she's a full-blown psychopath so
she's a psychopath and I think she gets
off on the fact that she was a literal
nobody and she manipulated and and house
of cards or Game of Thrones her way into
some relevancy where she does have it
she has a show she makes money off of it
she doesn't need Bobby to make money
anymore you know
um and she needs to kill him and now she
has to kill him and be the alpha
this is what I see I I kill him like
he's a [ __ ] Husky and you're a female
Hunter I can only do it yeah I can only
do it so I see a guy and he looks like
John Jack Nicholson but Jack Nicholson
from The Shining and he's Well Jack
Nicholson was Jack Nicholson from The
Shining
Bobby
I I have to hey remember the show that
now is getting the the Netflix thing you
could have been it with Jamie Foxx had
now got really good reviews and because
of her you went to a psych ward instead
because she don't want you to do the
ching chong voice the ching chong voice
yeah remember that and then we've
watched I watch Mad TV and literally
every character you did was doing the
ching chong voice
like just pacing oh God all over the
place right he's freaking me out dude he
could have just been sent to a lockdown
rehab facility where they whacked him
out on benzos but even if this is the
case kalila was the one who convinced
him to go to a different rehab center
she was also the one with the power of
attorney to get him out but still had to
read up on the place after he was
already calling her begging to get out
[ __ ] then I'll take you to rehab and
then knock you up on benzos
they don't [ __ ] keep a plethora of
but they don't keep a stockpile of
benzos as the rehab center they're
trying to get you off drugs not on new
drugs
I mean again it's water coffee smokes
[ __ ] shitty food they might have to
chain you to a bed while you [ __ ]
detox they might administer some stuff
that will help you like wean off of
stuff but you're not getting benzos and
by the way it's coffee with powdered
creamer yeah well I mean come on man
do what you can
this was only after he was able to
finally reach her he makes passing
mention of the fact that they were
having trouble getting a hold of her she
had a conservatorship on him the mental
place was calling her so he could get
out and she wasn't picking up no one
would no one would let me go they were
like no you know I mean we have to talk
this and that we can't get a hold on
this and this is days that go on I I
can't get out and I had to eventually
tell Abby I go threaten law so I I do
the Jew thing some
base
based
thank you Bobby
some believe that this is because she
took the time to go to Hawaii I haven't
been able to find any hard evidence of
this so basically the theory isn't like
he's saying there is no hard evidence
the theory is is that the reason she
could have got a hold of him was because
she was in Hawaii
the place she told him not to take
remember he could have got a job on one
of those TV shows in Hawaii and she said
no 25 million she said no that's what it
was yeah yeah I don't want you in Hawaii
but then now she's in Hawaii all the
time yes I don't want you to be away
from me and then she just goes to why to
[ __ ] some guy yep he says that it was
the other thing that he was referring to
the actual crime in which she told him
the truth about we talked about it yeah
you know that spoke about this and you
told me oh yes people believe that he's
referring to financial crimes
irrespective of this conservatorship
idea I think you mean it regardless
although who knows what it could be with
her I also found that Lila is listed as
principle for the tiger belly LLC no
no
[Music]
what is he doing oh no she's the
principal signer on the company
Bobby look man that's your show bro that
show was only exists because of you dude
oh [ __ ] oh he's [ __ ] oh he's [ __ ]
bro that's why when they broke up he
said don't worry she's still gonna be a
big part of the show
got no choice
no [ __ ]
see if you're unaware a principal
generally has financial decision making
Powers over a company all of this
companion yeah the principle yeah yeah
with her gold digging admission it's no
wonder why people are connecting these
dots it's all incredibly conspiratorial
but it's entertaining to break down no
conspiratorial or not and by the way
this is xlp also speaking of
conspiratorial for you guys
speaking of conspiratorial hear me out
on this sure
so Brendan and Brian started World War
Three
because
there were some IP addresses and there
were some email addresses and they had
traced a lot of this drama
back to Bobby
right
but what if it was kalila because this
would be right up kalila's house what if
the person sets fires that's what she
does what if the person she was doing it
proposing is Bobby she's the principal
in tigerbelly you know she has his email
address hear me out you know he probably
barely checks any of that [ __ ]
hear me she's running his life I think
she did it and then she and then Bobby
probably when this whole thing started
he took her in privately and said did
you do this and she said no and he's
like I believe you because that's the
one sticking point that that Brendan and
Brian have both been true on
it has been the there was there was a
there was an email that was from a from
the tiger belly themselves that was
running this right uh remember that and
then that email disappeared I'm saying
it it was kalila okay and here's what
I'm thinking now let me back up because
when this first happened I don't know
about khalila as much as we know now and
when we saw her with Brendan in that
interview when she was talking to him I
believed her but now watching these back
to back she's just tracks this track's
not Delilah she did this but she's good
at lunch but she's good at lying too
that's the other thing we just noticed
like you said she's a psychopath bro
she's a narcissistic psychopath and
that's my opinion by the way I'm not
diagnosing her or anything but I'm
saying that a lot of the traits of that
okay and and
what's to say that listen Bobby might be
an internet idiot but she's not
you know oh my God so I'm look again
conspiracy it's just a conspiracy what
if
big dumb Brendan was right about this
one thing oh my God can you imagine it
was her I'm that's my theory I'm putting
that I'm floating out there right
it was her and now Brandon and Ryan were
right
oh my God you think
it distracts for her think about it
you're right this would be exactly the
kind of [ __ ] she does abused people
start drama start fights
like she's she nobody shut up about her
since the [ __ ] all broke right she won
down nonetheless the last thing I'll get
into is our never-ending lies from her
self-harm to the origin of her
bestiality even her claims of division
one swimming she purports to have swam
D1 for the University of Las Vegas but I
wasn't able to find any proof of this
online I was however able to find dozens
of documents proving that her sister
swam here
oh my gosh
dude she did that [ __ ] yeah watch as
everybody's saying in the chat Papa was
right Papa was right oh my God I figured
it out I broke the case merch in the war
broke the case again